In this video, I'll take a
look at three functions--
with, within, and aggregate.
To explore these functions, I'm
going to load in the Mario
Kart data set.
The with function can be use to
access variables on a data
frame with ease.
This is especially important
when the name of the data
frame is long and multiple
variables are being accessed
for calculation.
I can read this command as with
mariokart, compute the
total price minus the
shipping price.
The within function is similar
to with except that it's used
to create new columns and
merge them with the
original data set.
For instance, here I'll add an
auction closing price to the
data frame and store the
result in a new data
frame called mk.
Notice that the commands to
generate the new variables
goes inside braces as
the second argument.
If I had wanted, I could've
added multiple variables by
creating more variables
inside of the braces.
As you can probably guess, the
with function is useful for
one off calculations, while
within is useful for expanding
a data set to include
new variables.
When I want to aggregate or
summarize results, I often use
the aggregate function.
Here, I'll aggregate across the
number of wheels and the
condition variables.
The first argument
is a formula.
The dot on the left side of the
tilde means keep all the
variables for the output, and
the variables on the right
side, separated by a plus sign,
indicate which variables
to aggregate across.
The second argument is a data
frame, and the third argument
is how to aggregate
the variables.
Had I only wanted to aggregate
across one variable--
say, the total price--
I could've replaced the dot with
the total price variable.
Notice the similarities between
what the aggregate and
tapply functions produce.
Which you should use depends
on what you will use the
output for.
Congratulations.
You've finished section three.
The next section will introduce
how to write your
own functions.